I'm not troubling you, but before you
get troubled, why is the blood of Abel
going to fall on their head? Who
Cain.
Do you understand what Jesus just said
about those Jews who rejected him?
He says Cain is your ancestor.
Because when Cain
Abel
Cain is your spiritual father.
You belong to him, not to Abraham.
There's that teaching again.
When Jesus said, "If you don't believe
in Christ, you do not belong to Abraham,
you're not true Jews." These Jews, by
rejecting Jesus and wanting to have
He says, "You belong to Cain.
You share in his
cuz he's your father, not Abraham."
Right there it says, "The blood of Abel
will fall on you, right?" Yes.
How can the blood of Abel fall on their
heads
if Cain isn't one of their ancestors?
Because in Matthew 23:32-33 he says,
"You will complete
what your ancestors began."
And one of their ancestors did what?
Abel. Yeah.
But that was Cain before the flood. How
is he one of their ancestors and why are
they sharing in the guilt of Cain
Oh, because the Bible says there are two
lineages.
Right.
>> Either you are the seed of Abraham and
therefore a son of God
or you are the seed of Satan.
That's why Jesus says, "Who are my
father, who are my mother?" I'm sorry,
"and brothers." Mark 3:31-35, you don't
need to turn there. Mark 3:31-35,
"Who are my mother and brothers? These
who do the will of God are my mothers,
my brothers and sisters." So,
if you do the will of God
you are a seed of Abraham, a son of God.
But if you don't do the will of God,
then you are of your father, the devil.
Now, who was Satan's first son? Who was
the serpent's first son?
I don't know. Cain?
Yes, 1 John 3:12.
>> Okay.
1 John 3:12.
Do you want me to turn there? Yes, read
it. So you can see I'm not making it up.
The first son of Satan, the serpent, is
Cain.
1 John 3:12.
Okay.
Okay. Yep, and that's what Jesus said.
They murdered the prophets, so they're
like Cain. Which part of Matthew
23:37-39 wasn't clear, Leo Sumi?
1 John 3:12.
Do not be like Cain, who belonged to the
evil one
and
his brother. Okay, so what did Jesus say
in Matthew 23:32-39?
"You will complete the sins of your
ancestors and all the blood
of the righteous that was shed the
righteous who were murdered
starting with Abel, ending with
Zechariah, will fall on you." But who
Abel, Cain. Who will share in Cain's
guilt? You read it, Matthew 23,
Jerusalem. Did he not say that? Mhm.
Why? Because God is saying there are two
lineages in the world. Satan's lineage
and God's lineage.
Satan's lineage and God's lineage. True
relationships are based on spiritual
spiritual connections, not physical. So
you can be a physical Jew and
spiritually a descendant of Cain
the seed of Satan.
You can be a physical Gentile, but
spiritually a son of God and the seed of
Abraham. That's the teaching of the
Bible.
So Cain belonged to Satan, right?
Yes. Now go to John 8:44. The Jews who
reject Jesus, who do they belong to?
John 8:44. I'm almost done, sister.
Okay, I was about to say I have to go
back to work. Okay, we're going to end
it right here then. We come back cuz we
got to do Romans 11. So let me know when
you're free to do Romans 11 cuz there's
a lot of these clowns, right?
A lot of these clowns who think they
know Romans 11 because I got to do
Romans 11 with you, all right? Okay.
Okay, so now
go to 44? John 8:44. But make sure give
me time this week so we can do Romans 11
cuz this is their favorite text that
they butcher like children of the devil.
Okay. Before you read it, why are you
calling me when I'm on a live stream,
Lazarus? You want me to block you?
Okay, go ahead.
You belong to your father, the devil,
and you want to carry out your father's
desires.
>> Wait, the Jews who reject Jesus belong
to who?
The devil.
That's their father?
And they want to carry out their
father's desires.
>> And he was a murderer and a liar from
the beginning, right?
Yes.
>> He was a murderer from the beginning,
not holding to the truth, for there is
no truth in him. When he lies, he speaks
his native language, for he is a liar
and the father of lies. Okay, did you
see? Now, who was Cain's father?
The evil one, the the devil, Satan. And
these Jews who reject Jesus, who are
their father?
The devil. So who is their spiritual
ancestor? Is it Abraham or Cain?
Cain. There you go.
Now, let me know if you have time
tomorrow, we got to go through Romans
11. I have to do it for you cuz these a
lot of these Bible perverts, these filth
that think they know the Bible and think
Romans 11 helps them, but it buries them
and their destruction
of scripture. So but we need to So
sister, let me know if you're available
tomorrow so we can do Romans 11 or later
tonight, all right?
Can I tell you just a takeaway I took
from this? Yes, go ahead. It it did get
Now of course, because I was Muslim, I
still have to look into different
You're breaking up. What was that? Look
into what? I just want to make sure
Oh, I'm going to do some more research
into this. I've never thought this way,
but what I did take from the Sam 100% is
um
I need to rethink about why I I never
saw the perspective of
the Palestinians, especially the
Christians that live over there. Yep. I
never
to
>> Evangelicalism, sister, in the West.
It's It's disgusting and perverted,
doesn't know scripture. Now, remember
this is the point I want to emphasize.
If anyone twists my words, may the Lord
crush their mouths and rebuke them for
lying and slandering. I never said be
anti-Israel. The Lord crush your mouths.
I'm just saying to those demons who want
to slander me. Nor did I say be
pro-Palestine. Let me repeat it. I'm not
being politically correct. You are not
to be pro or anti-Israel, pro or
anti-Palestine. You need to be pro Jesus
Christ, sold out for Jesus Christ, and
then be pro the rule of Jesus Christ. So
when the Palestinians commit atrocities,
you condemn it. But when Israel does,
you condemn it and you do not stand for
any human government, but for the Lord
Jesus Christ and stand for what is just
and right.
That's what I'm saying.
I feel like that's what we took away, uh
that your heart what you're saying is
that
we need to point people to Jesus and we
don't need to have this this anger and
and um
like cheering when other the other side
kill people.
Yes.
>> That's wrong. Jesus would not want that
and I Yes. I want to kiss your head.
Going to get
Okay, well thank you for your time, Sam,
and I hope I can meet with you tomorrow.
I have
>> Well, let me know because we got to do
Romans 11 so I can silence these dogs
who are going to manifest like rabid
dogs who think they're doing Jesus a
favor. We got to do Romans 11. Sister,
what you said, you took it took it
precisely. When the Palestinians see you
praising Israel as he holds the lifeless
body of his daughter
or infant baby, they hate you and your
church. They go, "This is what Jesus is
about? You can keep your Christianity."
No, okay.
Thank you, Sam. I hope you have a great
rest of your day.
>> you. Take care. Take care. Bye-bye.
Okay, brethren, uh I'm going to have to
retitle this. I'll do James White some
other time because it's 2 hours of
intense teaching and I have to get ready
to meet someone. I hope you're blessed.
I will, Lord willing,
I will, Lord willing, do James White and
expose him. Now, brethren, you're my
witnesses because the dogs are going to
manifest.
They're going to lie and slander me and
say I'm pro-Palestinian
and I'm justifying the atrocities of
Hamas against Israelis. May God crush
their mouths, rebuke them, and shame
them, and teach them to fear the Lord.
I'm on record, I'm not tickling ears. I
am not anti-Israel,
nor am I pro-Palestine, nor am I
pro-Israel, nor am I anti-Palestine. We
need to be about the Lord Jesus Christ.
Hamas is a cancer. May Jesus wipe out
But because my Hamas, they are dogs of
Satan who follow Muhammad who's in hell
under the feet of Jesus Christ. Look at
what they did to their Palestinians.
Why?
You got to be a special kind of
demonized, wicked, demonic filth like
to think by attacking non-combatants,
murdering Israeli children or
grandmothers, that this would not bring
on this backlash of Israelis dropping
bombs indiscriminately
thousands of Palestinian grandmothers,
grandfathers, and children.
What did you think you're going to
accomplish, Hamas?
May God save us from Muhammad.
May God, who is trying Father, Son, and
Holy Spirit, the Lord Jesus, erase all
of the
And may the Lord destroy all these
Muslim terrorist organizations.
Right? What did you think you
accomplished? You went in and
Israelis because you're occupied, not
thinking now there're going to be a
backlash of bombs
devastating,
leveling Palestine to the ground where
infants die and babies die and older
people die. Weren't thinking that?
Or was that deliberate on your part,
HAMAS? CUZ YOU WANTED THEM TO DO that
in order to cause more hatred, more
animosity, and more violence.
May God save us. Guys, pray for me and
my daughters. If you love me for the
sake of the Lord, I ask the Lord to
grant my daughters and I miraculous,
supernatural physical safety, security,
protection, and help. Ask the Lord to
give me discipline to die to my
addiction to food, to obesity, to get
healthy, and use my health to glorify
Jesus. Ask the Lord to give me the power
to die to my flesh and lust, and walk in
holiness and purity, and love the Lord
Jesus Christ. That I see my daughters
grow up to be in love with the Lord.
Provide through me, provide via PayPal,
Patreon to support them. And ask the
Lord to bring them to me now,
not later. We love you, Father. We love
you, Son of God, Lord Jesus. We love
you, Holy Spirit. In Jesus' name. Lord
willing, I'll review James White maybe
later tonight or tomorrow. Christ is
risen, risen indeed, and he's almighty
to save. We love you, Lord Jesus Christ.
Save us from these fake, wicked,
effeminate dogs who think they're
Christians. Silence them, Lord. And make
us bold, and to know your word, and to
live it out. We love you, Lord Jesus. We
depend on you. Amen. Come, Lord Jesus.
Take care, guys. See you soon. Lord
willing.